fleischel qui tente en fait jamais rien
avec kelly j'ai pas dit ça non plus ce
que je sais enfin pourquoi ça a foiré
entre maxime et kelly c'est quoi ça
parce que maxime est une tanche tout
simplement non même qu'en luttant des
grosses perches et notre app aucune et
pourtant kelly ya mis du sien l'a
carrément invité à dormir chez elle
j'ai les images mais vous allez voir
jean-michel à côté il est comme un fou
rival s'il se plaçait discrètement ça se
voit à peine
j'aimerais aussi que je commençais
d'allissa
l'histoire
chez moi
[Musique]
quel bon gars 3,2 à à jour là je triche
baraka d'héroïne
mais pas moi
je m'arrête j'ai pas trop parler de
benjamin ce soir ouais c'est vrai je me
sentais épargné en fait et ça dommage
parce que j'aime beaucoup mais c'est un
mec cool et à qui on peut parler de tout
en toute décontraction
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
foutu
[Musique]
déguisée de longtemps
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
3 2 1
il marche plus avec les routes
cette fois j'y vis bien